[Music]
[Applause]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on shotgun very
excited to be talking about comedy
talking about touring talking about
comedy showcase is performing for
colleges forming around the u.s. very
excited to have and Rodolfo joining us
on the show yeah what's up thanks for
coming on oh man thank you for having me
really appreciate it very excited very
excited we first met what was like two
years ago yeah you're performing on the
Eureka Science comedy shows yeah yeah it
was very exciting it was very exciting
and loved your work a lot and it's been
fun following you seeing you now doing
even more tours even more performances
doing your home showcase for those of
you yes yes I love the growth love the
growth for those that don't know Andrews
links are below in the bio he's been
doing this for six years now doing
comedy as a stand-up comedian during the
u.s. performing also he's co-hosting
along with Joey Avery who we've had on
the show he and Mark small so we need to
still have on the show and the pier 69
podcast and that links also in the bio
check that out
he's also the producer of the comedy
times pop ups shook comedy showcase that
happens in Oakland Monday at 8 p.m.
every Monday at 8 p.m. and cool cool so
that links also in the bio check that
out check that out for those that are
local all right let's start this off on
this beautiful big history perspective
we find ourselves we find ourselves now
on this playground called Earth
experiencing this human experiment what
are your thoughts about this I think the
earth is flat no I'm just like what do
you mean like a like my thoughts on just
like a billion of these advanced chimps
running around trying to socialize and
economics yeah politics I think we're
all gonna die soon but I think we're
gonna go out you know in a real fun way
I think it's gonna be real fun
we're very good talking right now things
are wild but you have fun in wild times
you know
it's good what's okay to things then
what's your most fun in the wild time
and how do you think we're gonna go out
I'd hope okay so the the way we'd go out
I hope it'd be like okay so like the US
or some some countries are going at war
right and we're all we're all about to
like god this is gonna end it but then
right before their bouts it's like the
country's about to go at it
aliens come and they're just like no we
take you out you know and then then then
we have to fight the aliens we're gonna
lose for sure but it'd be fun we see in
the end we'd unite to defeat the area
you know yes but we're still gonna die
it's it's totally fine well then I read
anything about the false flag invasion
upcoming false flag innovation that's
going to involve an alien attack have
you heard anything about no no it's
nothing just thing oh yeah well it's
funny that you said that about you know
these aliens yeah be prepared for a
false flag attack involving alien
disclosure coming to the planet and then
we're all gonna do a big kumbaya Lord
and come together globally that's the
plan but you know do you do you think
we'd win I could give a [ __ ] either way
this is good cuz if you if you do see
civilization like on the political side
all these governments and whatnot and
people still mad at each other arguing
trying to fight each other Marino
collapse and then there is something
that unites us you know that some force
that helps unites us to realize oh we
are all together here on this earth we
need to cherish that what about the most
wildest experiences right now before the
craziness like what is your favorite
part about the human
right now I just technologies so great
right now I could do it whatever I want
and I don't have to leave my house or I
don't even leave my bed like a live
stream the alien fight yeah watch they
in the bed and order [ __ ] from Amazon
yeah I'm just like going through
different like videos without China's
not doing too great oh my goodness that
that speaks highly to how
technologically advanced we are but you
know there's at times it seems like
we're still a little like ethically and
kindergarten like we haven't all evolved
yet in terms of you know our hearts and
in terms of our love and compassion for
one each for one another for all the
getting beyond this whole this whole
fighting yeah I feel that
and I feel like technology is so new
right now to that it's where we're
trying to figure it out so it's like we
can't figure ourselves out you know it's
like it can help in so many ways figure
us figure us out but it's also such a
distractive yeah tools or at the same
time are you and your phone a lot I've
I've finally in the last since 2019
since beginning of the year just decided
to start just keeping my phone off or
like extent I'm talking like days at a
time yeah it's fantastic yeah it's like
so rewarding and you already get your
email and your Facebook message all in
the computer anyway yeah I didn't like
cuz I I didn't I remember had a laptop
back in like I want to say like 2011 it
broke
I just never ended up getting one and I
just did since like 2011 to like I got a
laptop now like as of like little I got
one for Christmas and I didn't use them
for seven years yeah I didn't have a
laptop for anything you still have the
power supply from 2011 because
need a new one I think my see me after
yeah so for like years I just like all
my phone so I was like on my phone I was
calm down a lot you know but for a while
I was on my phone like a lot just doing
everything like trying to figure out
like doing work and stuff on my phone
emails and stuff so yeah I've been doing
a little bit better now
well also like it can exhaust your these
meat sticks like if you're trying to
just use your thumbs mm-hmm oh versus at
least if you get the full range of a
couple other next press keyboard with
yeah that can at least speed things up
you know cuz then you used the device
for less now I'm which is very important
which I'm very excited for you know
voice technologies are very excited for
everything that just takes us away from
the like the appendage that's yeah sleep
but it's also scary because you have to
trust the technology companies that are
gonna try and implant and rune let's do
let's do the conversation about your
role in this human experiment so you
know you you were you're born and you're
a kid and you're figuring yourself out
and then you figure out that you know
you like me we went to school for two
years yeah and then we dropped out and
then we you know we find ourselves you
know producing comedy producing the
shows right this kind of stuff how did
you how did that trajectory work out for
you how did you pick up your interest so
like how dice like start comedy so I
used to so after I went to after high
school I went to like a community
college for we're at Diablo Valley
College in Pleasant Hill or like Concord
area yeah yeah yeah I was there for
three two and a half three years maybe
just like I didn't even know what I was
even doing like I was I try to like stay
on a path and I can I like that past and
I go on a different one I did I did that
for the whole time I was there I never
really picked one thing
but I was working at a skate shop like
down the street from where I was going
to school and the manager of my skate
shop was like hey like I'm gonna go do
stand-up comedy tonight like let's just
all go and do it
so it was like I think like five of us
five of them just like after work we all
just like Bob did yeah we we got off
work or the ones who thought we all got
off early and then we went to our
friend's house and we just like all
wrote together just like in a room of
just like five of us writing complete
nonsense like it wasn't like number of
bits I'm like 20 or 21 at the time I was
like I I'm I don't remember what I was
talking about it was probably something
stupid that not like no one could relate
to and then we just drive down to this
comedy club in the East Bay called Tommy
tees and uh yeah they had like an open
mic that you paid five dollars to like
do yeah I mean there was like a huge
audience and like it was like exciting
and I was like the only one that's after
that I don't even know how well I did
I've been looking back probably I was
like yeah I did great you know but now
I'm like that was probably terrible yeah
yeah I just so much adrenaline nerves
you don't know what's going on yeah and
then uh I kept going and uh but the
manager my manager at the skate shop he
kept going for a little bit
he recently he doesn't do it as often as
I do but he's kind of still in there and
then uh everyone else was like I'm never
doing this ever again this is great this
is those moments of the kind of they
triggered like a butterfly effect in
some weird life and yeah that's that's
really nice we hear this as a frequent
thing from the guests that come on the
show and so you had that and again
you're talking about this you know the
adrenaline this experience and
performing in front of people that's
also kind of like a frequent thing that
people enjoy when they when they're able
to you
be communicate something of value
whether it's funny like comedy or
whether it's an idea that's really
profound for people yeah take a stage
and be able to do that's a lot of a lot
of fun and you kind of got hooked I got
hooked like
right away like kind of right away cuz
like I did I was like oh I got to do
this again like this is great and then I
was like I did fine I'll do fine next
time and then I go back the next week
literally like the next week and it was
like here we go and I went up there with
like different material than I did and
it was like one of the worst experiences
I've ever had in my life like yeah I I
was like wow like this is not what I
thought it was gonna be and then I like
stopped for I didn't do it again for
like probably like a month or two just
cuz I was like how do i ha I'm gonna go
back but I'm just like man I gotta take
some time off of this because this was
it kind of hurt is it a real like kind
of like reality check like my ego I was
like hey I can do this and then it was
like no you can't if they can't take a
joke I don't think it was this is why
comedy is probably one of the most
important like ego check experiences
because a lot of people think that
they're you know hilarious I remember
when you know my first couple times
going onstage to getting a couple people
to laugh out of the whole audience is
like awesome
Jimmy was great and I was like wow
awesome I got a couple people to laugh a
couple times and then you got to keep
going and shattering this
uncomfortability that you have and do it
over and over again until you become a
master at the art yeah
yeah it's because when I went into it I
was like I love that the joke writing
part of it the technical aspects of
comedy that was like my favorite part
that's why I kind of kept on doing it
and that's kind of where I I think I've
I found like okay this is what I like
because I got I feel like when people
find like what they want to do
they just want to figure that they're
not at it they might not be like the
best at it but they want to figure out
how they can at least get close to it or
fix what they did wrong
like like I've like in strikes in
science and stuff like that people are
always trying to like answer thing you
know answer figure out the right
equation or something like that and I
can for me it was like how do I make
these jokes like better funnier you know
cause like each joke is almost like an
equation or like a puzzle to where you
could find different solutions to get
the laugh which is the solution or close
to a solution you know yeah that's
what's fun for me about comedy yeah like
there's variables that's yeah that's
it's so much fun to like like have a
sentence and just like tweak like a few
little words or put something over here
versus over here and it just like
completely changes a reaction from a
person yeah yeah that's a lot of fun to
me the pause yeah is also very
interesting the the dynamic feedback is
really cool yeah you can tell when the
audience gets it and then if you make a
tweak maybe they don't get it as much
yeah you know more and that's how you
adjust and play yeah yeah yeah or just
you just like swap out like literally
one word and then it goes from like a
tiny laughs to like a huge laughs that's
that's so cool to me like just like
tinkering with all these different ways
I can play with words and it's it's so
much fun yeah yeah and I like how you
focus on the technical I want to let you
know we'll unpack that more as we keep
talking I want to hear about so okay so
as you're you know you're picking it up
post the the manager of the skate shop
introducing yeah yeah getting into the
flow of technical writing and performing
so then um how did you end up over those
you know those six years and in the in
this in this case especially in you know
in the Bay Area slowly going from local
events to touring events and then to
call colleges as well which I want to
talk
as well so yeah yeah what's that so when
I first started it was like remember out
dude just that one Mike at-at Tommy T's
on on Tuesdays I think it was on
Tuesdays I pay every time I would you I
pay every time and then I remember one
night I was with my group of friends and
someone was like hey we're gonna go to
another Mike another open mic in Oakland
and I was like what do you what do you
what you're gonna do - you're gonna do
two of these in one night and then he
was like yeah that's like late and then
I just got it my friends were like okay
let's go we just got in my car and then
we just kept we kept hitting more open
mikes and once you get into like the
more of the mics you get to meet more
people in the scene yes where you're at
and then they'll put you on other places
they'll show you and then you you just
find out like there's some so many
places you can get up and then you just
keep you just keep doing that and
eventually I would go up every night
like just not getting paid at all just
doing little sets for like almost no one
a lot of the times sometimes you get
lucky and you have like a big a big
crowd and that would be that'd be fun
and you'd hold on to that one for a
while that I think that's what would
kind of keep you going you'd you'd have
all bad set so then you'd have that one
good one in your bag okay that's hold I
let people to store that yeah yeah and
then yeah and then eventually like
people will see you you get better or
you don't get better and you start
getting booked and like I remember like
my thought process like when I was
trying to get better like how I saw it I
was like okay
when I was early getting booked I was
like okay try not to be tried to do okay
okay and then I was like if you can do
okay that's fine and then after I
started doing okay I was like okay let's
try not to be the worst person on the
lineup yeah so if I was just if I was
just a little bit better than someone
else or like just that I was like okay
good and then the next one was like
let's try to be closer to the best
person on the lineup and then now and
then you work towards that and then
after that I was like okay how can I
bury this whole show or just like how
can I just do the best you know
yeah and that that's kept me going and
then what gets you to from paying to do
the performance to booking two people
booking you and paying you to to perform
just the slow increase of getting better
right yeah yeah so like you'll you you
never know who's in the audience a lot
of times and a lot of the shows that are
run in the Bay Area are also they also
run other shows that are like good you
know so some people that run open mikes
will also run like a really good show
and then they'll see you at their open
mic and then they'll be like hey I like
you do you want to do this show and then
once you get on that show you're kind of
on which shows with like other good
people in the scene who are like
establish you also run shows so the Bay
Area is nice because it's like a it's a
it's a small scene it's not that big to
where like you'll be on shows with
people that are working and then they
also run shows and they'll put you on
that and then you'll meet other people
and eventually you'll use you don't have
to you can stop open miking or I don't
know if you could stop but like you
won't have to do it as much because
you're booked so you looked you're
interesting so instead of like mics so
it's like I remember I'd be going from
like maybe I'd do early in the week I'd
do a few open mics like Monday went
Tuesday Wednesday and then for the rest
of the week I'll be booked and then you
keep doing that and then eventually you
start also running your own shows
and this is interesting when did you
when did you start comedy times pop ups
that started almost three years ago
three years ago - yeah yeah we're almost
I think in a couple months we'll be at
three years and that's the round that's
the image of the black building so this
is an Oakland you've been doing this
three years you started producing your
own showcase so then you go and network
with comedians and then you get them to
come on to your showcase where you sell
tickets and you produce a lineup and
people come and attend your showcase and
you build up credit that way as well as
a producer you network more you get
better you see how other people perform
yeah yeah yeah cause like when you run a
show it's also just a it gives you
yourself like stage time so in you
so technically every Monday I am booked
because it's my show you know so
technically I have a show every Monday I
am booked every Monday in front of like
a great crowd in it so you can like put
that in your calendar and it counts
so when people see that you're like oh
he's booked a lot it's like well yeah
it's my show I do that myself but yeah
we I started that show with my friend
Irene - yeah super funny very funny
we'll we've been aiming to get her on
but she's in LA a lot right yeah she's
in LA now yeah yeah so hopefully when
she comes back up we can get her see you
guys some coke produce yeah yes she just
she's back most Monday's so she's
pleased there if you can get her on a
Monday like beautiful and I'll message
sure about that great yeah yeah we
started that because there was like no
Monday shows in the venue that we have
Starline social club and Oakland you're
super great bar like they have their own
little event space they have a few event
spaces so we saw there a small room and
we're like let's let's do something here
and then they did have a few shows that
were like on the weekends for comedy
comedy
I don't know that the bars pretty like
it's good it's a good bar so like on the
weekends it's like pretty packed and
it's like maybe not the best time for
comedy so Monday we kind of lock that in
and we started it every two weeks so so
two times a month second and fourth
Monday and then it started doing really
well and then we had like a few big
names like come through and then the bar
was like just go every Monday mm-hmm so
we're like okay yeah I'll go over Monday
don't yeah so now this consistency with
it it's just key with running a show
Yummie you know yeah yeah yeah
consistency because they know it's great
that you get the slot to practice as
well and yeah yeah and this is actually
a very complicated thing because you
have to you have to rent out the venue
you have to coordinate ticket sales they
have to go to us like some site to get
sales to promote it if the book this the
comedian's to come on you have to give
them slots you have to pick an order of
them this is all there's a drink since
do you know the bar wants to make money
this there's all of this and this is all
a learning experience so for every
single person that's that's listening
you know really think about what you
love doing and go and produce something
that you love doing and get more and
more practice with that and that's what
it's great if you start twice a month
producing something then you go down to
once a week then then you're started
doing it every day you're performing or
almost every day you're performing
comedy and we're performing our show and
stuff like that and yeah that yeah it's
a new rhythm and can when you when you
produce your own show it's it's great
because you you're learning you wins
weekly we we learned everything from
like producing just from like this you
know it's like a lot of trial and error
and when you can do it more you figure
it out faster ya know so in like
currently right now I have a we're we're
lucky in the Bay Area for like live
performance like comedy music and
because since San Francisco so
tech-heavy
like everyone is checking social media
so like and there's these few key
websites here in the Bay Area if you go
to the if you get your event on there
you pretty much have a sold-out show so
it's it's like fun cheap yeah fun cheap
if you get on fun cheap for the Khazar
shows on fun cheap and if you get on
front you you're guaranteed at least
somebody you know so yeah that's it's
great that's why I run like I have three
weekly shows now I have one on Monday
Tuesday and Wednesday so just because
out out here it's it's pretty easy it's
not I mean you have to figure out how to
get to it like yeah the social media
sites and stuff but once you figure out
the pattern how it works it kind of goes
on autopilot and then you can run
multiple shows here you know because
once like it once you start a show after
it's gonna be rough for like a few weeks
maybe a few months but once are people
knowing about your show and oh if its
weekly if it's consistent yeah yeah
people just know they just know they
just tuned they can tune in whenever
they want that's your show they could
maybe they'll miss the previous episode
but they'll come back for the next one
you know because they know it's it's
there so every Monday people just know
it's it's there they can do it as a date
night as a fun yeah they don't they
don't have to be like is it wait what
day is it is yeah so okay let's let's
talk cuz this is good we got to this
equation side of things and plugging in
different variables and tweaking words
on the technical side that delivery all
that stuff producing your own show the
last three years with RNA awesome and is
Irene or IRA night Irene Irene Irene see
I need to get that right Irene so and
then so you guys producing that for the
last three years again another huge
growing experience meanwhile you know
this is cool you were teaching me about
NACA yeah now NACA the National
Association for Campus Activities yeah
which I didn't actually know there was
like a you know like the National
Association for these campus I can
just like you this is where you can get
picked up as a comedian to go perform at
colleges yeah so that Mac is interesting
because it's it's kind of it it it
almost is like almost like a level up
and that's that third or the next image
Ron the one where he's standing on the
yeah yeah that one yeah oh yeah yeah hey
Michael it's my buddy Pedro Gonzalez
shout-out super funny comedian in New
York Joe check him out said it's a next
level up it feels that way cuz so - in
order to do NACA
you have to like I was lucky enough to
like I've made connections over the
years to where some people have helped
me out to get like a NACA
like a like a college agent so they I
with them and they help me submit to
these NACA conventions where are these
big conventions all over the all over
the country I think there's like six or
seven regions where they showcase
comedians and music magicians it's
everything it's anything that your
campus can have like to to entertain the
students so it's like magic music comedy
balloon animals face painting caricature
drawings like someone that can just come
to your school like escape rooms yeah
yeah they could mobile escape rooms it's
pretty cool but to get in it you have to
like submit your tape to a committee of
college students college Booker's
they're all they're all like young
adults and they watch your tape and then
they decide if you what they would like
to you to showcase for them in front of
their region of colleges yeah so and
your tape has to be like super clean
like the cleanest you'll ever be that's
a comedian like you can't swear you
can't you can't really touch on a lot of
picks Jim this is that political
correctness thing yeah yeah oh damn yeah
and and then if they like you
then they'll they'll let you showcase
and then you clean up good yeah yeah
it's super interesting
cuz then you'll go to like these a
couple de convención this where they'll
be like all the student Booker's so it's
almost is maybe like if you're in a
region like a regional one say I'm like
it like the West Coast region then I'll
showcase for I don't know over like four
hundred student Booker's yeah like and
and you're just you're fought you're
following so many different kind of acts
so like you'll have like a slam poet Oh
interest like it go before you and
they'll talk about something intense
like very yeah you know something and
then you go up there and be like comedy
yeah this is different we're like a band
will Russian like that sometime last
year I there was like a band or like a
group who like just crushed like did
this whole all the students got out to
start dancing like and then they get off
and then I have to go up and then I'm
like a little switch it's happening
right now and it went fine it was okay
but yeah you do you do the this tape and
then it's like a short tape it's like
probably like three to five minutes yeah
like a highlight reel yeah your work
yeah and they they only have to watch
like a few seconds of it they don't
really yeah yeah like I think cuz they
get a lot of submission they get a lot
and then they want to find the best ones
and they look at your social and your
calendar see how many you're to INGOs
they check everything they check just to
see if like you're safe we're to hire
yeah this is kind of crazy this the same
thing okay maybe before we get into the
safe thing let's let's just finish up on
this because you called it like to this
next level up I think this is really
cool is that you can you can come find
these these things like NACA that can
get you a step up in the scene and
there's kind of plenty of these ways if
you're like you indicated earlier
producing your own show gives you step
up doing something like going to Couture
and collegiate campuses to perform
another one and you get paid yeah
for that well which is great as well so
there's like these different steps up
that you can take and then other
thoughts on the college before we get
into PCR do you want to go in no we
couldn't do it let's go it feels like a
step up just because like you're going
from like very little money and then
people are actually like really trying
to pay is it's a very interesting
experience because you'll do these
showcases and if you do well these these
these kids don't know like you really so
like they can't they would like I know I
did Nationals recently which was like in
front of all the colleges and damn yeah
it was it was like over a thousand kids
yeah and then I did well and I still
live here in San Francisco I don't
really have like that many like good
credits or anything like that but the
kids with college and hey can I take a
picture with you and it just feels weird
it's like it's like you know I'm going
home and eating McDonald's like right
when I get to the airport yeah not cool
yeah I'd see you on like Twitter and
Instagram like these kids tagging me
like hey we just met angel rofo and then
it's just like oh but I I appreciate I
appreciate it they're they're great and
doing the actual colleges is very fun
it's it's it's a cool experience some
sometimes not sometimes
okay so here's thing you're breaking
through another one of these in walls of
adversity which is well we face when
we're trying to get on stage 4000 people
you know there's a huge one I love that
yeah that's a really powerful one to
shatter through and get really good at
over time and then also these colleges
are all they're kind of like competing
to get the best like activities for
their CES and so they're trying to get
the good towel into magicians comedians
bands etc yeah sometimes it's just like
they hire the comedian to just be like
here's okay you got pool on this side
but if you go a few steps over here
there's a comedian you mean so you say
like I remember one of them I did was it
was in like what is was the word like
it's not like a like a rec center yeah
like a rec center of like one of the
colleges and I was like in one of the
rooms is like a pool hall yeah and like
like arcade games and like I was in like
the cafeteria kind of like they had a
stage but I was maybe like from well
what was Ron Ron yes from I'm sorry from
here to Ron here to Ron was at Auntie
Anne's Pretzels as I'm telling jokes
there's just a bunch of students in line
we're getting back down and at one point
I was like yo auntie Anne Scott just
give me something so he just like handed
to me while I was on stage it's just
like so yeah that's a lot of it some
some of them are really great I've done
some colleges where it's like like a
theater full of kids but then yeah
there's there's another time where I did
a college whereas in a theater but there
was only like 20 kids in like a 200 C
theater with the lights fully on yeah it
is very awkward awkward experience this
these are the different experiences you
get as you climb up then you get better
yeah yeah okay let's do this what is
going on with the political correctness
like you got it like
you know through that you're real you're
three 5-minute real can't be have
anything inflammatory no no no no like I
know I mean I'm George Carlin was saying
some truth he would never get to do
these colleges which is too bad because
a lot of the 18 to 22 year olds need to
hear some of the things that he said
yeah yeah yeah so that yeah the tape
that you submit it's like the cleanest a
comedian will probably be you know like
cleaner than even being on TV cuz like
on TV you could say like [ __ ] yeah I
got like [ __ ] at least like once or
twice you know you know I don't know the
regulations on swear words but you can't
even you can't do that at college just
like that's because it they they just
want someone who's to be on the safer
side to please like everyone you know
cuz they whoever they book it reflects
them and it's yeah yeah
no nothing inflammatory no offending
anyone with your comedy that's a hard
thing isn't it yeah yeah how do you find
no one I guess you can see it's like
even if you even if you make a joke
about wealth inequality make a joke that
can like kind of like punches at rich
people in some way yeah there'll be some
like rich kid that gets offended ohm or
whatever you know it's like kind of
crazy that yeah my show in Oakland it I
consider it's probably one of them the
more like woke audiences you know so you
kind of have to work around some stuff
but you could I mean it's not like a
college but it's like I got remember I
did this joke about you know transition
glasses aren't that lenses that change
yes like like as my dad has those I was
doing a bit about it how I don't like
them and then a guy in the audience
stood up goes walks out the door and
right before he closes the door he goes
you [ __ ] [ __ ] and then leaves
because he was wearing up but I mean it
was just like it's why get upset of that
you could just buy different glasses
yeah but yeah the four colleges you have
to be super clean and then when you do
if they pick
you then you get to showcase and do
maybe like seven to ten minutes of clean
but you could you could maybe go a
little bit off yeah yeah just to buy
like a little maybe you could say [ __ ]
yeah you know but you you don't want to
talk about totally like politics there
or something like gent like gender or
whatever and which is it's just fine
like yeah there's so much more material
yeah you can do there's you can there's
so much out there yeah yeah but then
once you once you've booked the college
then it's up to the campus how you
you're set goes so like I will call them
and be like hey I'm coming to your
school in a few weeks just wondering is
there anything like I can't talk about
oh that's a good that's a good thing to
do you know just so I prepared me and
like I then if because a lot of the
times the colleges are like do whatever
you want
oh damn yeah do whatever you want just
don't talk about like most of the time
like I'll get like don't please don't
talk about sexual assault which is fine
yeah yeah I don't do that anyway yeah
that's easy and then one time I got
don't talk about like physical
disabilities which is also easy like and
so the otherwise it's pretty otherwise
you can do whatever you want they're
like I could talk about sex whatever cuz
I mean like yeah they're there's they're
learning about it anyway you know I
think it's just that they're maybe not
as such an advanced level as I am yeah
they're doing some of it you know maybe
not like on an intimate love and
compassion they're not using toys yeah
yeah it's it's it's fun like some the
the usually they're like do whatever you
want it's cool
and it's a lot of fun it's really cool
and then okay give me your give me your
synthesis on the state of political
correctness and comedy period
so as
so in as a comedian and I'm like
thinking with my comedian brain like
sure some of it is like kind of I
wouldn't say it's like an annoying at
all but it's just like okay I can't I
feel bad for other comedians who are
like trying to like push the edge you
know I mean at mic my stuff I don't
really do that much I talk about silly
dumb stuff like a little weird stories
of how I like I'm like not a smart
person you know so it's just like I and
all are not smart real opinions on think
you know so I just talk about silly
stories just bit just be silly and I do
I can't appreciate like like dark jokes
dark humor I think you're like from from
the technical aspect of it like a
well-written joke I can appreciate yeah
like if someone does a joke about like I
don't know any any taboo subjects if
they have like if if the if the equation
is there and any I can appreciate it you
know I can appreciate that so if the
technical side if the equation is
drafted in a way that makes the
punchline which might not be politically
correct but if it's funny but if it's
funny and it does a good job I may be
communicating a lesson about maybe not
killing other humans or yeah yeah yeah
like I'm super like about that you don't
I mean it that's cool to me like and it
kind of sucks that some comedians who
some of my favorite comedians are
they're kind of like upset about PC
culture because I can't like say what
they want and I kind of get that but I
also can appreciate change like
everything changes yeah you know and it
does I mean ethics evolve this is yeah I
don't think piece of the culture is bad
at all like I think it's like I think
it's great but PC cultures doing a lot
of good things this is an important
point so okay let me ask you let me put
it this way that as PC culture does its
job at making sure that we no longer
make really really stupid jokes that are
in sour taste about about serious
traumatic events that happen to people
being raped or or or people that are
going through a serious like murders
happening on the streets and stuff like
that like you know these are very like
how do you you know there's a very
strange way to craft an equation that
would get you way evolved people so
ethics away from murder or away from
rape right but like the point is that
you want to help people move their
ethics away from racism and sexism and
bigotry of all sorts right yeah so
that's kind of the point is to move
people on this spectrum more towards
like you know you're moving they call
this the Overton Window it's like though
the window of accepted ideas tend to be
able to have right you're opening the
window of possibilities more in the
direction of progress yeah yeah and and
you're closing it off in the direction
of of where we came from which is a lot
of violence and bigotry and stuff like
that so so that's but you're moving that
side fast yeah hey and I yeah I yeah
that I agree with all that but also as a
comedian like my comedian brain is like
I do like hearing a well-crafted dark
joke you know it's just so fun you know
it's great but III like I'm not I don't
hate the PC culture at all I like it I
think it's it's a step in the right
direction it's like it's cool you know
and also I think it is cool that it kind
of challenges like me as it can be and
other comedian I find it as like I've
got like a cool challenge like like how
how can i navigate through these kind of
like taboo topics and kind of and
actually like make it funny yeah you
know it's it kind of
it raises the bar for writing you have
to write more clever you have to write
better now that you have kind of like
they're kind of like obstacles like BC
culture is kind of like an obstacle I
guess for some comedians but it's like a
it's not a bad one let's take a good
obstacle that like to try to get over
like yeah yeah cuz your writing is just
gonna get sharper you're you're you're
gonna I feel like you almost get you get
a little more intelligent about yeah
like things like that so yeah no I agree
with you
yeah I agree with you that's that's
right you're you're given another
challenge that you have to you know
tweak your formula to you know get to
evolve the ethics of civilization in the
election progress I'm I agree with that
side I also want to just make sure that
at the same time we have the nuance of
be very careful with how much you try
and limit some of the Overton Window
conversations because you may think that
you're moving people towards progress
but in many ways people that think in
Copernicus ways in the way of the point
one percent and in the counterculture
ways where culture is moving 99.9
percent in one direction you may have a
thought that maybe that know the star
doesn't orbit the Earth Earth orbits the
star right you may have these profound
countercultural thinking that that we
can't just close it off because they
lose a very serious idea yeah what are
we doing oh thank you well for four
minutes over there okay thank you Ron I
thought we were around that time thank
you for that okay so quick a couple
things on the way Ron Ronnie will you
show the image of the last one that we
have from Pier 69 sure cool so the last
image that we have here to show this is
another one of that things you guys are
so what's your boys name here yes dad
named yard dud
yeah that would name your name yeah and
Doug would name here because I remember
meeting him at the setup as well I don't
think I followed up with him we should
you know get him on the show too but we
boys coming on for around on simulation
we got to make that happen
this I want to I want to say again this
is one of those things that you do that
ups your game again because you're you
know these are the things that you have
to do you have to go outside your
comfort zone what is it like to start a
podcast what is it like to to work with
this is the pure 6:9 podcast links in
the bio and you know Joey Avery right
here was on the show before yeah I know
and so this is this is again I just want
to touch that
I just wanted to touch on this quick
just that it's another one of those
things that you've got to do you guys go
weekly yeah it's weekly ever yet we we
record every Tuesday release everyone's
day yeah usually or we release night up
if we don't have to edit yeah mm-hmm yep
yeah it's because the way like social
media is right now and like the
entertainment industry there's like
there's so many ways to I guess make it
you know like which is like which is
very cool but also it's almost there's
no it's a little overwhelming there's
because like I guess like back in the
day you you had kind of stand-ups head
like this path like you just you do
stand-up
you get late-night you have your own TV
show that's how it is but now there's so
many other ways to make it there's like
YouTube Instagram even you could just be
an influencer you stand up just
podcasting you and a lot of the times
now like when people are looking for
people to be like I guess like
like have like a when they're looking
for talent it's like beyond like a like
a TV or something like that or just
successful in the entertainment industry
like Bill people liked it the industry
is like okay well okay you do stand-up
what else you got
so now you have to yeah in that it's
it's like now I have to learn how to
write up like it's like a TV show I have
to have a podcast I have to do these
YouTube sketches I have to keep up my
social media accounts every day just
like yeah in it's it's a little
overwhelming but at the same time pretty
cool that any of these avenues can lead
to something great so you bring up
another interesting double-edged sword
which is that you have we have so many
options with technology in terms of us
finding new ways to carve our path up in
terms of influence and making a bringing
value to other people but at the same
time when you have to post on the
platform to stay relevant and whatnot
then I'm just I'm interested I think
sometimes we create more noise into the
sphere then if we were to not post on
the platform work on something
creatively and then post that on a
different platform that were maybe more
we were better at or what not I
sometimes feel that way a little bit
about the way that we use social is we
try and keep up with it so much that we
put more noise into the failure yeah
definitely definitely yeah yeah with
social media like like Twitter and
Instagram definitely like a lot of that
is just yeah you throwing things at a
wall and just hoping someone yeah likes
it but like with the podcast and
like YouTube sketches you could really
be creative on there and stand up
because like when I when I start when I
started doing comedy I was like okay I'm
just gonna do stand-up and then people
or just I've constantly telling me
that's so what that's that's not enough
anymore and that made me have to well
what else do they want you to do you to
write people want me to write cuz like
if you're looking for someone if an
industry person is looking for someone
to make them like famous to make them
money it's like okay are they gonna go
with the person who's really good at
stand-up just stand up or are are they
gonna pick the person who is good at
stand-up but also good at writing and
has a paw and has a podcast you know
yeah yeah it's pretty strong showcase
like yeah this the more things you can
check off on the Box the and I always
thought like if I'm doing stand-up and
then I veer off to some other path that
my stand-up is gonna suffer you know cuz
I wanted to do focus just like stand up
stand up stand just be a great stand-up
and then I started doing I started
writing scripts we started writing
sketches and then I started to realize
like oh it's it's not just my brain is
just it's getting an even bigger workout
than it was yeah yeah so you can
literally see with neuroscience and
neural activity you can see when people
are more creative have larger more
complex social networks that they're
they have a good more brain structure
developed out themselves this is very
exciting their frontal lobes are larger
this is oh yeah it's a very enhance this
is a very interesting field of like the
go deeper into your field that yeah
you'll become smarter like yeah cuz like
when I would I would write I would
definitely I'd write my stand up like my
bits and work on those at night and then
I'd shoot these sketches or I'd write
these sketches would like my foot the
podcast friends and
stuff like that and then I'd be like
okay this is it's making my brain work
you know thinking about comedy in a
different way to where now if it didn't
work at the sketch I would apply it to
stand up and it maybe it worked for
stand-up and then vice versa
and sometimes we'll be doing the podcast
and we'll have like a like a great bit
on the podcast it's like a fire riff and
then what else then we think what else
could we use that for yeah so then we'd
have we take that bit that riff and then
the lute and I or something mark and
Joey we take that idea and just expand
on it in a sketch yeah and now that's
like a whole new thing yes yes you know
and sometimes it might fail on stage
because it didn't translate from yeah
yeah there's all this yeah but these are
new ideas that can interplay two quick
questions on the way out I feel like did
we do yeah we summarized we did good as
fun I hope it wasn't too comedy we did
do a lot of comedy but no we did we did
a good amount on unload their subjects a
lot of the touch talked about drugs
[Music]
listen Ron my niece watches this show
calm down over there that's Ron's s runs
on go joke all right the two quick
questions on the way out
cool this is simulation yeah are we in a
simulation man
I don't think so but I would love it if
it was you know that's that's I think
that's really like I don't like the
whole world is a simulation I actually I
don't think so
and so if it was then can someone make
my life better like what are you doing
help me out a little bit yeah that's a
thing your characters got a level up
yeah let's do the hard work to level up
my character that's how the life gets
better all right and the last question
is what do you thinks the most beautiful
thing in the world
there's someone following someone just
not getting injured but like see someone
on the street slipping like a little
slip and just like that's like one of
the that's one of the most genuine
moments that you'll get out of a person
just you'll see you see everything in
that moment you know you'll see them be
embarrassed you'll see this is really
good if you really bring the way you're
breaking it down it's great because you
do get to see because you know went for
example when you walk and you slip and
you're like oh my god who just saw me
and you're all like worried and anxious
versus my walk and slip and you're like
yeah you really get to know a person
just from watching like be that
vulnerable like when they like so I'm
not saying Gary I don't want anybody to
get hurt
but just like you know just like you
take a misstep on like a curb or like a
use of funds on ice because then you
really get to know that person when you
see them how they handle it and then how
they go out from that situation because
some people you could tell that they
suck by the way they try to pull off
thing and though they're super cool and
then it's trying to be awesome and cool
cuz then it when it cuz then it at first
it was funny now it's like man like that
this person sucks and then if you see a
person and then they like slip and then
they they laugh at themselves laugh at
themselves like a bow so you can tell
that person doesn't take themselves too
seriously and it's even more funny in
some exactly yeah that's interesting
that you said that that's the first time
we've had any also I will never be as
funny I don't think any community but
that's like a thing like no comedian
will ever be like as funny as someone
just like slipping
as long as you're not getting hurt yeah
yeah awesome this has been super fun
Andrew thank you so much the show I hope
it wasn't to blame no it was super fun
it was great hearing about your journey
there were a lot of really good
takeaways Andrew said that oh oh you're
your notes yeah there will be nothing
for you to write down this profound but
no there were a good amount of things
that that I got I got a write down
thanks so much for coming on all the
Andrews links are below everyone go and
check out andrew's links check out the
comedy showcase that happens in Oakland
on Mondays at 8:00 also check out the
pier 6-9 podcast links below editors
website links below yes I plug one plug
plug okay so on March 30th Oh March
March 30th that we're doing the pier 69
podcast is doing a live album recording
of all our stand up it's gonna be a
compilation album we're all doing like
shorter sets like 10 10 minute sets
it's gonna be real fun it's in a secret
location okay BYOB and you can find all
that information that don't tell Comedy
dot-com interesting don't tell comedy
calm okay we got to remember to put that
as well in the bio I love this we got to
have pee or 69 on let's make that happen
Angeles have to love them on there'll be
a lot of fun
check out the links below huge thank you
to Ron Vargas for producing and
directing we love you very much thank
you thank you all writers and everyone
support the artists and entrepreneurs
that you believe in go and help them
succeed our links are below for
simulation too if you believe in us help
us out please and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world we love you very much and
we will see you soon peace
[Applause]
[Music]